[Music]
aaron is starting us off in salt lake
city utah hi erin welcome to the ramsay
show
hey dave and john it's a pleasure to
speak with you today you too what's up
so uh my wife and i are getting really
close to getting out of our uh student
loan debt
and we're really looking forward to
living the debt free lifestyle cool and
we're just curious we still have a
couple credit cards open
and we just want to know like how that
works in closing those down and what how
long is the process
it takes to basically get rid of your
credit history and credit score
well your history will stay with you
seven years from the date of last
activity on each item 10 years if the
item was a chapter 7 bankruptcy so if
you close that credit card account that
account will show up for seven years but
it'll get
obviously progressively older and when
someone looked at your credit bureau
report they could tell hey they closed
they closed that credit card five years
ago and so it really doesn't start to
count in any way for you against you or
anything
after a couple of years but it still
shows up
now that's that's the show up part
if you shut down every single account
you have no outstanding
credit
account of any kind
and they're all closed and zero balanced
about six months later you will have no
credit score
might be nine months might be nine
months might be 12 but somewhere in that
six to 12 months
okay so in in when we're looking to move
or eventually buy a home
those things won't show up in say a
couple years and we can do the whole
underwriting process that you talk about
they will show up but you won't have a
credit score and you would do a manual
underwriting with a zero credit score an
undeterminable credit score
so
so for instance i filed chapter 7
bankruptcy when i was 28 years old i was
38 years old and it was still on there
but it didn't count against me
anymore because it was 10 years old you
know at that point and i wasn't
borrowing money anyway so it didn't
matter but and it doesn't it did not go
towards creating a credit score there's
no activity so the first thing i did was
make sure everything was shut down and
closed and zeroed
and there was no continued activity
because if you have an outstanding bad
debt that stays on there because they're
gonna they're gonna keep act keep adding
activity to it where they're trying to
collect what you owe
so bad debt being on there will keep
open your credit score and keep it low
uh but you'll if you have zero accounts
of any kind
showing up on your credit bureau report
as active
they're all closed and they're all zero
balanced then uh it doesn't take that
long for your credit score to evaporate
which is wonderful i i've had some
instances over the last few years where
just buying
maybe buying insurance or buying a
cell phone
a lot of different companies are asking
hey we want to run we just want you to
know we're going to have to run a credit
report on you
and it's and i tell them i'm paying with
cash the gab is just part of the thing
and it seems like more and more that
score they want to know who they're
dealing with well they're trying to
figure out if they can sell you
something is part of what they're doing
in some cases now with insurance there's
insurance gets rated if you don't have a
credit score okay you're going to get a
little more expensive right okay because
there's a bogus study
uh that was done probably 25 years ago
the university of texas the university
of pennsylvania did it together
that showed that people with low credit
scores had a
paid uh had higher claims
on their car insurance and their
homeowner's insurance were more likely
to have a higher claim on their a claim
at all and a higher claim
what they didn't the reason i call it
bogus is which doesn't make sense
because these are broke people so they
say that's that's but that's bad that's
bad statistical fishing there well the
but the thing they left out the reason i
call it bogus is they left out the
person with a zero credit score right
which you would find someone like me
almost never files a claim right because
i've got tons of money in the cash and i
just pay cash and just fix the car or
whatever it is i mean so so it it uh you
know if they had done the study a little
bit more thoroughly someone like but i
pay a higher
car insurance rate because i have a zero
credit score huh that's fascinating and
uh you know so that that's but that's
yeah that's and it's just because it's a
bad
you know the entire industry used it as
an excuse to raise rates so it was a bad
study why would somebody in your net
worth situation still carry car
insurance well you carry liability
because you have to yeah that's right
legally well and it's inexpensive the
liability portion is i actually carry
full yeah coverage anyway
because i drive expensive cars and it
just i just it's because you know and
i've got what's called stated value
we're not going to negotiate about the
value of the car if it's gone it's just
gone and you just write me that check
gotcha and that's a little more
expensive too so it's a high but a super
high deductible
carry a huge deductible but an expensive
vehicle you know you're driving a
hundred thousand dollar raptor yeah you
know or eighty thousand nine that's not
a raptor then that's you know
in that situation you're probably going
to make sense of it i still do i still
do carry those but there's it's uh at
that point it becomes the decision i'm
going to pay this money for the yeah for
the the sole tax right yep yep so we're
thinking about it just taken care of and
then i think about it i like that um but
the uh
and the deductible the high deductible
makes the price reasonable yep so run
the deductible way up
uh but anyway the so the
but on the cell phone
uh that's completely bogus yeah
they'll sell your cell phone with that
oh absolutely yeah and uh and what i do
in those kinds of situations because my
cell phones are through our company
we've got a bazillion cell phones so
it's a different it's a corporate
contract but if i were walking in and
some situation pops up like that with me
today or with you today i just go uh not
only do i have a zero credit score but
my credit bureau reports frozen yeah and
so you can't access it so good luck with
that yeah it's not gonna it's not gonna
work out you want my business right not
gonna work out for you do you want this
money or not you know and they're like
okay yeah we'll take your money that's
right okay and we'll figure it out yeah
yeah
and uh but there's very i mean i've not
had
any services of any kind that i've
wanted denied
in
20 years yeah i've never had anything
denied but in the first 10 years when i
i mean when i started this stuff with no
credit cards i was walking around with
no credit card they didn't have debit
cards
so you had to have yeah so
i'm like yeah and i did run into places
that you know i couldn't get in a hotel
without a credit card you know i
couldn't run a car
with a cash and there was no debit card
as a substitute that was just as good
you know so i didn't have that as an
option and uh of course in those days
online didn't exist right the internet
had doesn't exist in that in that decade
so uh but that you know it was
interesting i
went to speak one time on people getting
out of debt and uh they had reserved the
company i was speaking for had reserved
me a rental car when i got off the
airplane they wouldn't let me have it i
had to call a cap
wow
[Laughter]
that's ticking to your principles though
man
yeah
not not having another credit card i'm
done with them forever that was 30 plus
years ago